hi uh i'm a full-time professor here
i also am italian-american and i happen
to agree with the protester
in the back well i have to say as a
professor
that you would come i really appreciate
that because i know students come out a
lot but professors don't always come out
to hear opposing points of view so
that's a wonderful thing
it's my duty um
but i've left you speechless i've
dazzled you thank you
in you know in 1492
before a racist and genocider
came to this land there were people
living here
every inch of this land was occupied
just as a as a matter of history not
every inch of the land was occupied
it was it was there were huge areas that
were completely wilderness
i'd like to i was quiet the entire time
you spoke
there those people still exist
the north american indigenous people
central and south american
they're still here and
i would like to know how you can say
that they have no ancestral claim
to this land and that as a white person
you can say that they cannot migrate
freely and cannot use the land freely
that they
rightfully own and have for thousands of
years well mike i'd like you to be more
specific which people specifically and
which land specifically because there
were lots of different peoples
in the northern and southern uh in north
america and south america
at the arrival of christopher columbus
so which people do you think have a
claim to which land
i'm talking about the native americans
but there were many different native
americans you guys need to name all the
tribes
yes sir i'd like you to name it and the
reason i would like you to name all the
tribes is because there were many tribes
who conquered many other tribes so just
as an example
that's thank you just as an example the
comanche indians come in and they
conquer areas run by the
apache indians now the united states
comes in and it owns that land
to which tribe should that revert to
which tribe should that land revert the
comanche who had it before us
or the apache who had it before them
moreover
for the people who still exist you're
referring to christopher columbus in an
ahistorical way
by calling him some sort of racist or
some sort of genocidal
maniac the man never committed any sorts
of genocide at all
and he was actually known among the
spanish explorers
for his good treatment of the natives
that point is neither here nor there
and i encourage people to read
biographies of christopher columbus
because there's a lot of historical
fiction out there
the point on that is that when the
spanish came to this country they did
into this continent they did create a
new race
known as latinos this is a mixture of
spaniards
and native american populations so if
we're going to revert certain land to
native populations
why would we not then immediately take
that land away from them because they
also descend
from spanish explorers in what sort of
atomized way
would you define your own race your own
identity
i think this is a very backwards and
ultimately
impossible view of personal identity
that that puts your
your stock in some particular ancestor
rather than something that is larger
than yourself i think it's a madness of
the modern left
and it leads to to crazy policy
proposals
such as saying that somebody who
descends from a native population in
colombia
has a right to move to any apartment he
wants to in new york
because of race or something
we can certainly have a response thank
you for
not answering my question and in the
future i think
how specifically could i answer your
question if you could not lower the
microphone until the person's done
speaking i think that'd be better for
everyone
thank you that's all so you were done
speaking